ça devrait se jouer maintenant par tout
ce qu'il a laissé quelques coups de
transport les gens vont vous a parlé
parce que c'est ça le coup le plus
important qu'on ait à subir la région
c'est le coût de transport et le préfet
avait totalement raison
on ne les transfèrent qui est qui qui
coûte quand même chiant à la réalité
qu'on a c'est la di stasio le prince
pont qui s'ajoutent sur les factures de
tout le monde ça c'est certain
bienvenue en mégane i une des six
régions de la côte-nord un immense
territoire mais faiblement peuplées 6500
personnes derrière ses paysages à couper
le souffle une réalité moins reluisante
faire son épicerie coûte cher on est
loin de l'ensemble du québec on est
quand même 13 14 heures de route de
montréal thunder de québec
on sait combien plus cher les résidents
doivent payer la dernière étude de 2000
on nous faisait vais pour sa plus cher
donc ses impôts diminuer au contraire
peut-être que ça s'est accentué un peu
presqu'au bout de la route 138
un peu plus de mille personnes vivent à
natashquan et dans la communauté innu de
nutte à quad louise caillouette est
propriétaire avec son conjoint de la
seule épicerie dans un rayon de 150 km
si on regarde ça de l'extérieur on va
dire avoir baissé la seule épicerie fait
qu'il n'y a pas de compétition c'est
qu'ils peuvent nous vendre à n'importe
quel prix pour nous offrir n'importe
quoi ça marche pas mal ça marche comment
benoît ont été punis avec son bolide
il ya une des prix nous quand même je
suis acheter des fruits légumes mais là
aussi le même prix que n'importe où dans
province
c'est sûr que des choses sont un peu
plus dispendieuse par rapport au coût de
transport qui sont élevées qui joue dans
entre 40 et 50 mille dollars par année
quand on doit tuer parce que les
distributeurs bien toi jusqu'à nous fait
quoi dans ce temps là on est obligé de
majorer nous prient pour absorber ces
frais d'eau
la plupart des aliments vendus ici
proviennent des entrepôts sobey's située
à terrebonne et québec
l'épicerie doit aussi faire affaire avec
des distributeurs indépendants pour
certains autres produits comme la viande
qui se vend seulement sur je n'ai alors
les gens qui veulent avoir de la viande
par exemple du boeuf haché pour moins de
deux livres lui 100 grammes ces 15
dollars au même moment les consommateurs
dans les grands centres payer 10 $ 50 ma
viande rouge publie le monde change le
port le beurre ne pas le choix parce
qu'on a des frais de transport etc sont
exemptés bon ok là comme le pet la règle
de paris
ça me coûte 110 15 pièces plus la
surcharge carburant
ça veut dire ça me revient à peu près
entre 40 et 50 cents par part pour le
brésil qui est tout autre aliment comme
ça vous n'avez pas le choix de vendre
plus cher qu'ailleurs bas le lait le
lait le que c'est le plus onéreux
parce que le même faire appel il me faut
au pot
résultat le lait coûte 16 % plus cher qu
presque partout au québec les résidants
n'ont d'autre choix que de payer ce prix
encore faut-il que leur nez soit livré
la réalité d'un contenant c'est qu'il ya
une route
alors si la vôtre coupe ski une réalité
à aa
c'est une réalité l'hiver il peut y
avoir un blizzard l'appui il ya une
journée où personne semble assez comme
ça
alors oui à des enjeux assurément
d'approvisionnement les livraisons dans
cette région arrive aussi par bateau
mais une seule compagnie offre ses
services
on est transport maritime qui dessert la
mécanique il 55 % du temps cet
éloignement a aussi des impacts sur le
prix et la fraîcheur des aliments tandis
que si lorsque sa route par bateau puis
que le bateau saute le voyage puisqu'il
fruit de sens qu'à blanc-sablon puis
reviennent du bâti le programme figurent
des fruits et légumes frais lots
proposés date depuis dix jours de jeu
quand ils reçoivent plusieurs villages
sont ravitaillées uniquement par avion
ou par train on a aussi une certaine
urgence
j'imagine que les prix d'augmenter
devant tous ces obstacles
on est en droit de se demander si cette
population vit en toute sécurité
alimentaire tels que définis par le
gouvernement du québec est ce qu'on peut
dire que ici dans la région chacun peut
se procurer en tout temps une quantité
suffisante d'aliments sains et nutritifs
pour mener une vie saine et active y
assurer à ses enfants une croissance et
un développement adéquat de réponse et
dont 25 pour saab et gel c'est sûr que
ne peuvent pas atteindre ces standards
l'eau on est tous deux régions atypique
donc on vit avec soyez de résilience
mais c'est certain que on peut pas dire
que partout on peut se procurer des
fruits frais en abondance
on parle même de problèmes de santé
publique ou sur ce plan autochtones et
non autochtones sont égaux quand je
pense aux personnes par exemple la baie
johan beetz sont à 65 kilomètres d'ordes
saint pierre il était une période de
leur vie où il y avait même pas un
commerce de proximité
ça ça veut dire revenir acheter une
pinte de l'ale si je manque de lait au
matin ces 120 km le pour ma part
les distances organes dont il faut
subordonner à partie le transport mais
les gens qui nous écoutent 3 0 mais vous
n'y a tellement peu de population
ça coûte tellement cher est ce qu'on va
injecter encore plus d'argent
le contenant on va présenter un pour
cent de l'ensemble du québec en
population mais notre pib revenant 2.2
pour ça écoutez on est dans une région
de ressources naturelles ont contribué à
la richesse du québec hydro-québec ses
revenus nets la passe excellent vin à
5.3 millions bon tout simplement au
québec d'une simple pour vous contribuer
à combler un coût beaucoup plus à votre
échelle à la nôtre